the US Navy hospital ship comfort is
admitting coronavirus patients but that
wasn't the ship's original mission
they're open BAE I see something that
wouldn't say you incidentally see an
American hospital anymore it was
supposed to help New York hospitals
overwhelmed by the pandemic by taking
non coronavirus patients off their hands
officials had previously expressed
concern about what bringing coronavirus
patients in would mean four others on
board if we open it up to kovat patients
the likelihood of infection of our
doctors goes up to ensure that whatever
we can do we are doing after the comfort
could only fill about 4% of its capacity
with trauma patients New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo requested that President
Donald Trump designate the Comfort to
treat coronavirus patients as well but
the Navy said it found a way to isolate
crew members and patients by dividing
the ship into a green and a red zone in
the red zone are the doctors and nurses
that interact with patients once the
approximately 500 medical staff members
are done with their shifts they are
taken off the ship to an isolated
undisclosed Hotel on the green side is
where the crew members run auxilary
services and the ship's plant these crew
members stay onboard the ship in their
own individual staterooms crew members
are not allowed to go back and forth
between the red and green zones
Governor Cuomo said on Tuesday the
ship's capacity will also be cut in half
to 500 beds
Kovac patients require a greater
treatment area more space and therefore
the capacity shift came down from 1,000
to 500 it's still a tremendous benefit
as of Tuesday evening there were five
coronavirus patients on board the
Comfort a Navy official told reporters
that the patient's had tested negative
when they boarded the ship but later
tested positive patients who were in a
less dire situation are being taken to
the Javits Center while those who may
need intensive care will be treated at
the Comfort according to multiple media
reports a crew member aboard the Comfort
also tested positive for the corona
virus and has been isolated officials
said the incident will not affect the
ship's mission and ability to receive
more patients before the corona virus
cases were reported the Navy had strict
intake rules people had to first be
taken to a hospital to be screened and
tested once they tested negative which
could take hours they were taken by
ambulance to the Comfort but the process
done through a central communication
system turned out to be long and
bureaucratic the head of one Hospital in
the city describing it to the New York
Times as a joke on top of that officials
have also said that a shelter-in-place
order in New York may have caused a
decrease in traumas injuries from car
accidents or assaults things the comfort
was there to treat so the original plan
which was the comfort would take non
Kovach cases from the hospitals didn't
really work as of April 7th the ship
with a capacity to treat a thousand
people had treated only 44 people now as
the comfort takes kovat 19 patients on
board crew members say they will do all
they can to help during this health
crisis despite the risks this is the
national crisis and their loved ones in
Norfolk
[Music]